[Music]
before diving straight into the more
specific characters and personalities of
any game I'd like to put together a bit
of an overview of the full story first
this can then act as a sort of reference
point for future videos and can also
help for anyone new to the title so with
that in mind there are spoilers
contained in this video so if you
haven't yet played this game and want to
experience it yourself I recommend
turning off this video now otherwise for
anyone else I present you with the story
of Ghost Recon wildlands
[Music]
[Music]
Bolivia South America is home to the
Mexican drug cartel Santa Blanca as they
continue to grow in power and influence
the country is being transformed into
the world's largest producer of cocaine
in the earlier days of the cartel the
Bolivian government set up a special
forces unit called unidad the aim was to
shut down the cartel by cutting it off
at the knees but this didn't go to plan
Santa Blanca already had too strong a
hold on the country by paying off the
police the courts government officials
and even members of the Special Forces
unit within no time thousands and
thousands of bodies started showing up
politicians journalists police officers
the infrastructure of the country was
beginning to collapse running out of
options the new president made a deal
with Santa Blanca you stop killing our
people and will look the other way the
United States was forced to enter into
this conflict when the American Embassy
in Lopez was the target of an attack an
explosive device was detonated outside
injuring two marine embassy guards two
days later a DEA Special Agent Ricky
Sandoval was found dead it's believed
that Sandoval was the intended target of
the bombing Sandoval has been in Bolivia
for the last six years investigating the
local cocaine industry and it was the
close personal friend of CIA contact
Karen Bowman
a Ghost Recon fire team is deployed into
Bolivia as part of Operation Kingslayer
which is a joint operation between the
CIA DEA and the Joint Special Operations
Command the omission to take down the
group responsible for the Embassy
bombing and the death of Special Agent
is Sandoval
this group that Cermak skin' cartel
Santa Blanca Santa Blanca is made up of
four pieces production smuggling
security and influence at the top of
this all is the boss of bosses el Sueno
the only way to stop them is to take
them down piece by piece the ghosts who
are US Army Special Forces deal with
highly classified missions and operate
as a small unit stealthy and quickly the
ghost scent of Bolivia with the CIA
contact Karen Bowman they meet Pat
Qatari the leader of the Qataris 26 the
only resistance against Santa Blanca in
the Bolivia region in order to gain
support from packet re they're asked to
rescue our Maru from Santa Blanca with
the assistance of the Qataris 26 the
ghost dismantle the cartel piece by
piece targeting their four main
operations by attacking cocaine
production facilities and stockpiles
disrupting smuggling operations
discrediting the cartel and the eyes of
corrupt politicians and supporters and
inciting conflict between the cartel
senior figures
eventually the ghosts are contacted by
el Sueno he meets up with them
attempting to bribe the ghosts for
working for Santa Blanca the ghost
refused but in this situation learned
about the fact that it was special agent
Sandoval that was responsible for the
Embassy bombing in an attempt to force
the United States government to
intervene in Bolivia
bakatari eventually claims that have
found el Sueno but after investigating
the ghost instead find the body of our
marui packet re then breaks their
alliance and takes Bowman prisoner his
reason being that the Qataris 26 need to
be the ones that killed the leader of
the cartel to avoid being seen as
puppets in the United States the ghost
planned an operation or elsewhere Nia's
mausoleum before Peck guitarra gets to
him after a lengthy fight against both
rebel soldiers in the cartel the ghosts
and moments around el Sueno who is
holding the civet head of packet re el
Sueno surrenders but at this time Bowman
receives a call
elsewhere Nia has already made a deal
with the Department of Justice to give
up the heads of other drug cartels in
exchange for immunity
[Music]
how things go from here depends on how
the operation has been handled basically
there is two possible outcomes if the
ghosts have been fully dismantled the
cartel bowmen will go on to execute El
sueño this leads to a dismissal from the
CIA and her a risk for murdering El
sueño Berman doesn't regret what she's
done and informs other concerns that if
she hadn't done so the El sueño would
eventually end up becoming a dictator a
dictator with the backing of the United
States however if the ghost had fully
taken down the cartel and everyone
involved with Santa Blanca moment
instead takes away Nia into custody
true to his word elsewhere Nia provides
intelligence on the other drug cartels
terrorists and armed smugglers the
Bowman expresses concerns that after his
Intel is worn out that he'll either be
extradited to Mexico or be let free
Bowman and the ghosts prepared
themselves for the possibility of the
cartel starting up again in the future
and for the cycle to start over
you
[Music]
after the fall of El sueño there are two
additions to the story in the first DLC
called narco Road a CIA infiltration
specialist is sent into Bolivia to
identify the elusive head of Santa
Blanca smuggling network el invisible
the special agent poses as a mercenary
for hire and works his way into the
gangs carrying out smuggling operations
every leader that is approached provides
clues to El Invisibles identity before
being assassinated eventually the agents
standing within the game is recognized
by El invisible and is recruited however
el invisible is aware of the agents true
identity and has them imprisoned using
an informant senior sir Issa the agent
escapes and gets hold of a device that
el invisible users to run Santa Blancas
smuggling operations killing el
invisible in the process however once
the device is decrypted it releases a
virus that compromises the CIA from here
the agent figures out that some
researchers actually el invisible
himself he organized this operation to
escape Santa Blanca and disappear the
CIA then spend the next two years
tracking him down el invisible is
eventually found in Arizona and the
agent is assigned with hunting him down
and having him assassinated in the
second DLC fallen ghosts the ghost recon
team returned to Bolivia
although the cocaine trade has collapsed
with the death of PAC Atari the
guitarist 26 have resorted to infighting
the Bolivian government attempted to
restore the previous special forces unit
known as unidad with troops from across
Latin America to be renamed as los
estrange eres but the previously the
unidad forces turned out to be corrupt
and seize control of the cocaine
production
a data breach in the CIA is at every
active agent in the area compromised so
the ghosts are back end to rescue the
agents upon entry into the bolivian
airspace the helicopter is shot down it
has then recommended that the Qataris 26
is rebuilt in order to help defeat the
loss extreme terrace the commanding
officer of the law sixth Ranger oz
colonel Merlot was forced to take charge
of the remaining forces but was
eventually overcome the fall of the law
sixth Ranger oz created a belt of
infighting and opened up another series
of scandals within the Bolivian
government the ghosts and the CIA agents
are left wondering whether everything
they've accomplished here was enough to
change the future of Bolivia or if they
just opened up the gates for a new
dictator to come to power obviously this
is a very summed up version of the story
there are a number of characters and
events that have been left out but if
there is any interest I'll be breaking
down and digging a little deeper into
the law I actually quite enjoyed putting
this together although I've played a bit
of the game I never really put too much
energy into following the story that
closely so it's nice to put it all
together in one place so I can start
researching into it a bit more also it's
really made me want to play through the
campaign again anyway that's enough for
me thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one Cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you